I'm away by land along rebound the
d-wave rockets pushing junior out Eric
Jones junior plays the game above the
rim he is fun to watch how about your
Miami Heat the way they're getting it
down the floor
three-on-two activity there and rockets
going right over at the top to the super
athletic so worried about it was
shooting the ball steal by the heat
defense this is Liggins waiting for help
here at khakis Derrick Jones junior with
a piercing chin lettuce ISM if it's not
BAM it's this guy Derrick Jones jr.
right down the middle
get out of the way Jew with this Randle
wow that is just dotted line take off
[Music]
Jones junior
to the sky for another foot back waiting
having a cup of coffee wait for that one
to come along
that was crazy we talk about basic
Richardson damn Anna bioody Eric Jones
jr. shirt the second half of a neato
linic Kelly gets the rest of the night
off and there he is again
Derrick Jones jr. how so that is his
fourth dunk of again
what's attraction this is much of its
great defense by Whiteside way down the
middle off the spin on Augustine junior
above the rim for the flush for 12
shooting open the ballgame for Miami
Dwyane Wade to the second straight night
first up at home check nice Jam a man
who plays the game in airplane mode
strong Derek toads jr. always moving
without the basketball funky time to
beyond the arc
Hornets came in with 33 triples in their
first two games that's the most of the
league for Derek Jones jr. that's
athleticism the crossover and here comes
the pike as he rises head above the rim
one more look take that they're right at
40% a time when it's with 82 points 27
of them from Walker
I steal by Jones jr. look out tonight
second slam dunk of the night for the
man they call an airplay bug eight
minutes left in the first half Charlotte
eight-point lead is their biggest of
again nice pass Derrick Jones jr.
catching the one better
good to see the athleticism of Derrick
Jones visit the pace and they're gonna
need him to play here in this front
corker limited at only Udonis Haslem
left on the battery gorgeous left-handed
spike slam dunk for Derrick Jones jr.
the elevator man white jug still back in
the heat locker room after getting poked
in the on their toes with a monster left
here the June
five points for Garrett Jones jr. off
the bench seven point he lead
this is leaf and John Crotty I'm Eric
Rees thanks for joining us
dinner towns home on a cloud piercing
catch him finish for Garrett Jones from
Tyler Johnson 33 left of a fourth
quarter
Ellington working hard to get free fires
misses
[Applause]
he didn't do anything wrong he went
right up but just powered his way
through if he doesn't hang on there he
falls on his head and Jenna later on
will dive into the Eastern Conference
she and Lisa Cameron said he's backing
up to you mighty still in the hood
there's a nice flop and finished Erik
Jones jr. from Tyler Johnson you're
right that reap off they keep moving it
and not the number one or two of those
looks like but look at this incredible
display of athleticism he knew he was
going to miss that shot in her shift at
the Kuzma pass with 40 seconds left in
the head but the play of a half the
skyscraping group scraping done puts it
inside junior with a left-handed slam
dunk you know the shot clock Richardson
gifted with an open three bested Derek
jr. I told you to watch your phi you
make you jump out of your seat off the
miss look at him hang and the hard
finish with the left hand if they can
get healthy then I think we'll have a
better hostage
[Applause]
it comes Garrett Jones flying out of the
rafters and slamming it home write a hit
front of Opie Taylor Johnson comes back
to make the play defensively for the
steal down the lane Derrick Jones lucky
was shot from a cannon Derrick Jones
with another explosive finish gaining
cry waiting to the table he'll come in
next whistle for Cleveland there's Tyler
Johnson one bounce for Derrick Jones
junior killed
every time he goes up for a dunk it
better roll those tape machines ports
there's McGruder for three weight loss
Garrett Jones swims a dream he's so
quick to the basketball and even quicker
to the room finding a way to contribute
a lot of hustle for him defense got
cracked on the nose and he's still out
there comes junior pulled up put the
ball on Whiteside but Derrick Jones with
a full run oh that is just so nice to
look at right there and John Collins
grabs the rebound off throws it back in
to Derrick Jones looking water waiting
and here's the pitch ahead in the vision
by Dwyane Wade Jones jr. trailing behind
and perfectly timed play this is hole it
in the pain fines Derrick Jones for the
two days of jam but two schools have two
dunks for Derrick Jones jr. that's been
a tough game to watch the heat struggle
Jones jr. from Winslow man is a change
other than the coach greatness an artful
finish for Derrick Jones jr. the part we
don't have the ball one of the great
ways to be involved as to cut hard and
they keep playing uphill large part due
to the turnovers are six already for
Miami
Derrick Jones jr. a turnaround James
Lawson coming up Richardson has it for
miles
Celtics get that Derrick Jones gets
nasty
oh my the left hand I can never look at
this
Russia Marcos smarts been shooting a
ball much better beyond the Arctic and
you put a hand in the guy's face like
that your numbers percentages go down
look out Derek Jones with a slam dunk
waiters to three Derek Jones on the fire
does it a second time around underneath
Weston again looking for a last charge
waiters to Derek Jones hammers at home
Erik Jones jr. now with 15 points off
the bench
here's a hit by one Derek Jones jr. I'm
the tribe hangs in the air and dunks it
home you talk about a quick quick leap
for a second chance school for four
minutes left in the half bam with the
steal the lead for Garrett Jones comes
flying in from a flush super fly soars
and scores again Miami you know the
defense has been so fun comport with
allowing the heat to get out on the
break all year long Derek Jones on
left-handed throwdown 14:40 reaches his
first score in the second half
are you true the Cavaliers over the
closing moments but they keep putting on
their finishing crush Derek jump a great
defense
oh ma you can't do it any better than
justice just did it
wait aa Jones jr. average at home
Electrify incredible athletic play the
playmaker wade in airplane mode ladies
only an 11-point lead with a minute ten
left in the third from the left side of
your picture no one puts a body on and
he just explodes to the rim in from
being overly aggressive attacking two
countries that had a lot of respect for
each other hold on speaking of respect
tarik tombs hurting his one don't get a
tone this time it's a off a pass Jay
rich his ability to his terrific for
young man wasn't drafted after playing
up an only end of your key to it right
to jump Junior
it's actually played in three of the
last four games look at that extension
boy it just cranks it back so long place
so much bigger he took off well outside
the dot of the night there to get eight
points a game with Richardson
jamming Jones jr. with his second dunk
in a row they're scrapping for the
rebound
Richardson laughing Jones finishing
jamming Jones jr. does it again his dunk
of the night that gets them the one man
up advantage in the score double on
dragons nice pass by side Hawley he took
advantage of the double near midcourt
and Whiteside delivering a very crafty
assist the Jones junior and they've
really feasted on the Southeast Division
with after today's result they've got a
12 and 2 against the southeast 7 and 1
on the road against the southeast
[Applause]
believable he had to throw that in
because it was a couple looks here BAM
throws it a little wide he has to crank
back watch how he doesn't dunk it he's
throwing it in he just spiked that ball
in how does that go in on that angle if
he doesn't throw it in perfectly that
hits the back of the rim and goes flying
about 15 rows into the crowd that was
uncanny finished look at that
athleticism that's amazing
my and catching it on catching it on the
right and finishing with your left is
awkward - he's rearing back his head is
up a boat that left spin back to the
middle with a right hand finish
Richardson to Joe Jr it's a jam-a-thon
[Applause]
oh here comes Miami it'll run out Jones
jr. missing out her first getting in
right back
[Applause]
rated dunkers wellness shot clock
BAM blocks Meritus with under a minute
left him again slam down by the slamming
machine Derrick Jones jr. it's it's only
two points attempt on the future track
its the bench its Jones jr. both arms
extended offer great inbounds lob from
Dragon little bacon Rockets goes
upstairs much more aggressive
offensively at home number three in
points per game and 117 at home playing
a fairy Mason the magic on a 13-2 to
world leaders after Jones jr. gets into
the finish Chris Bosh to jump right out
of the seat and finished with authority
stretch it out large group of Slovenians
are here tonight to watch rockets do
John ships but they get a full dose of
character should get over draaga juice
in speeds right let's take a closer look
Trog it's doing a good job actively when
they're hitting shots 39% from the 351
from the field
oh what a catch at Venice alley you
reverse style with a foul for Derek
Hills junior year on the weak side
that's Dorian finney-smith he's got a
guy in that cult first team all-nba
centered issue 26 points in the paint
Mariana vichy he's got 12 of the 10
above them Simmons Witt says hope he
picks up right where he left off when he
starts his fifth season acute junior
with a wind-up clock
three players that played all 82 games
two different times
BAM swings in two years it down this
will be a new franchise record for the
nets in bench scoring this season
averaging 47 point seven the Japanese
rising up effective how much you'll miss
Dwyane Wade next season tonight stay in
the moment and enjoy
[Applause]
from the wig Duncan's going to go with
the lob pass nobody puts a fingernail on
him and when you let him get up there he
can hang around it's the first time
you've given us going away here comes
Winslow and a steal and the seat Jones
jr. slamming and swinging it's all the
setup here justice Winslow
Derk Jones jr. waited for the rebound of
your accomplice he's our racehorse the
take the flush and a foul coming right
here he just took off and got to the
reversal what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content